hi thanks everyone for being here i'm
stephanie forte with the southern nevada
bicycle coalition
yesterday marked the sixth six-month
anniversary
of the december 10th cycling tragedy
how a community responds in the
aftermath of such an event says a lot
about
its integrity and its character and
since that time
much has been done to improve safety for
vulnerable road users in southern nevada
and cyclists are in that vulnerable road
user group
so we're going to talk about some of
those things today
but we still have a lot of work to be
done and we're going to talk about some
of those things too
but before we get started i wanted to
thank you
for your continued coverage of the
education campaigns that the coalition
has rolled out
over the past six months and that
includes change lanes for bikes
that we launched in january and ride
safe
that we launched in may so while
we can come up with education campaigns
and lawmakers can do their job
what we really need to see is a shift in
mindset and a shift in behavior
especially
when people get behind the wheel so that
when they see a cyclist
the first thing they're thinking of is
change lanes
and how that happens and a big part of
that happening is in the stories that
you write in the segments that you
produce
so we really appreciate you being here
today because you are a really important
part of
the equation of creating change in our
community
so with that being said our speakers
today
include rob hutchinson who is president
of the southern nevada bicycle coalition
and kelly brooks who is secretary
clark county commissioner justin jones
and pat treichle
the founder of ghost bikes las vegas we
have two
family members who have been gracious
enough to join us
especially at this very delicate time
and that's donna troger and angela ahmet
all of the speakers will be available
for interviews after the press
conference
but we ask that you stay on topic and
talk about
talk with them about the work that has
been done
and what we want to see happen in the
future to make our community safer
so now without further ado i'm going to
introduce
rob hutchinson and keeley brooks
hey guys thanks for being out here
recently
i had the opportunity to have lunch with
a dear friend of mine i haven't seen a
long time
and during our conversation at lunch we
talked about what is important to us
so we haven't seen each other in a while
he asked me and
you know family came to mind was very
important to me
but in my life i have two families
my other family is my cycling community
here in southern nevada
and with that family is team g
tom aaron
axoy michael
gerard
this year i have decided to dedicate my
life
to bicycle safety and awareness in
southern nevada
and i decided to make it my life's work
so that we can have a goal
of zero fatalities and i want
it to be known that i'm i'm doing this
in honor of my family
and that is my bicycle community
and to talk about some of the things
that we've already done so far as a
coalition
i'm going to turn the time to keeley
hi uh keely brooks and um as
as rob was saying we've we've been
fortunate to
launch this campaign um change lanes for
bikes
not fortunate we've been unfortunate to
launch this campaign as a
as a way to try to educate motorists
about the three-foot move over law we
we're one of five uh states that
actually
has this this changed lane law and what
it means is that motorists should
actually
move around and take um give the cyclist
an entire lane when they overtake the
the cyclists there's 33 states that have
the
the three-foot law and that means that
the
motorists should give at least three
feet and so we wanted to do this
change lanes for bikes it's the law
campaign in order to just
come out of the gate and get motorists
to know about it so that they will it'll
be top of mind
and so we continue to try to come up
with these education campaigns because
it's clear through this tragedy and in
the past that
we're not we're not getting through to
motorists so again it's extremely
important and helpful to have you here
so we thank you and i'll hand it over to
commissioner jones
thank you robin keely these guys have
been in the movement for a long time
fighting for
cycling safety wednesday night i was
headed to an event down in
searchlight and just talking with my my
friend in the
in the car i wasn't really paying
attention and just as we
kind of crested a little hill on us 95 i
caught the memorial
on us95 of where this uh
cycling tragedy occurred and i got
really choked up
just thinking about what the families
have been going through
for the last six months and i hope that
it is not in vain
as we continue to work for work towards
the kind of changes that we need to make
sure
that we don't have the same type of
tragedies going forward
at the clark county commission soon
after the tragedy in december we started
a conversation
about what we can do better in clark
county to make sure that our roadways
are safer for cyclists and pedestrians
and as a result of those discussions we
made modifications to our ordinance
that governs what people are supposed to
do on the
the right side of the road when a
cyclist is on the road
the the rules of the road say that they
ought to stay to the right side of the
road
but as all of us who live in in las
vegas know
that isn't really always possible we
have sawtooth roads
we have roads that don't have bike lanes
and so we made sure that it was clear
when cyclists can take the entire lane
in order to make sure that they're safe
and that discussion led to an even more
important change
senator dallas harris reached out to me
and asked what she could do what the
legislature could do
in order to make sure that our roadways
are safer and so i started off the
discussion with her
sort of using our ordinance as a
starting point
and her response was okay let's do that
but what else
and so as a result of senator harris's
work and our colleagues in the
legislature
we not only were able to pass the same
type of cycling safety
ordinance for the entire state that
clark county had went down the path of
but also to clarify the
requirements for roadway design to make
sure that
complete streets principles are
incorporated and what that means
is that all users of the roadways not
just vehicles are considered in the
design of our roads here in southern
nevada
in on top of that something that that
robin keeley and i have been working on
for a while
is making sure that when you go to
driver school
that when you get a ticket that you get
the additional education
about the rules of the road when it
comes to cyclists and pedestrians
and we were able to get that passed
through the legislature also
so again nothing will bring back uh
the folks who rode their bike that day
but we want to make sure
that as much as we can we will prevent
these types of tragedies from happening
again
so with that i'll turn it over to donna
hi my name is donna tralger i'm tom
trauber's wife
today we're here to talk about creating
impactful changes going forward
i know i've already talked about the
nevada highway patrol's failure to
secure a warrant
and obtain a legal blood draw this is
the reason that jordan barson is now
sitting in prison only facing a minimum
sentence of 16 years
rather than the 56 years he should be
facing our life sentence
but today i'm here to tell you another
story
i want to tell you about my experience
the day of the crash
as you all know the crash happened on
december 10 2020 at 9 39
a.m i was home i was alone
i was in my kitchen making fig jam i was
oblivious to anything going on
at about 11 o'clock in the morning james
emery sent me a facebook friend request
i didn't know james emory at the time
and i've always received facebook or
friends
requests from many of my friends cycling
and triathlon friends and
i just ignored it and went about what i
was doing
and then about an hour or so later i
started getting texts from our friends
in the bay area
they said please tell me you're okay
i'm praying for you i'm hoping this
isn't real
and i thought maybe i better accept that
facebook friend request
and so i did and james emory said please
call me it's important it's an emergency
i'm with tom
so i called him and he was crying
and he said donna i'm so sorry
and i said what happened just tell me
and he said i'm so sorry
but tom was killed
and i was in shock i couldn't believe it
as i said i was alone
and i hung up the phone and i just fell
on the floor
my arms became numb my hands locked up i
couldn't even open my fingers
and i just was able to turn my cell
phone over and
dial my mom's number and when she
arrived at my house i had to crawl to
the front door and pull myself up to
open it
everything that happened after that is
kind of a blur friends came and family
came
and everyone started calling everyone
they knew the hospitals
the police that they knew or had
connections with to try to find out what
happened
i wondered all day if the news that i
had received was
the right news you think that when
something like this happens people are
rushing around and
i was hopeful that maybe maybe tom was
taken to a hospital
and maybe james missed that i called him
back a couple hours later and i said are
you sure
are you sure it was tom and he said
donna i ride my bike
with tom every tuesday and friday i'm
positive i'm 100
positive but i still wasn't convinced
i wasn't convinced until about seven
o'clock that night
when we called the clark county
coroner's office and they confirmed that
they had my husband
this is how i found out no one official
ever contacted me no one called me no
one came to my house
i wondered all day
in fact i got a notification from my
garmin
when you have a sports watch and you're
someone's emergency contact
you get a notification that says that it
detected
an incident in your tom trauger's
emergency contact and it sends you gps
coordinates
and i opened up my phone and i drilled
down on those coordinates and
indeed it was the clark county's
coroner's office
this is how i was informed about what
happened that day
here's another story on march 8
2020 there was a fatal bike crash in
annapolis maryland
another impaired driver on cocaine and
xanax hit a group of cyclists head-on
killing one and severely injuring
several others
since then i've become friends with the
widow of that cyclist that was killed
and she shared with me her story
from that day five troopers came to her
house
sat down with her two that were trained
in grief counseling
and told her what happened they asked
her to call a friend and they waited
with her until someone came
that's what should have happened that's
what needs to happen
we need to improve our procedures at the
scene of a bike crash
we need to improve our procedures for
contacting families
we need to provide training for those
who are the first responders to families
that are grieving and in shock
all of the work that we're doing here
today with the southern nevada bicycle
coalition
all the work that's being done it it
comes from the dedication of all the
people that are involved and it also
comes at a cost we have a facebook group
called team g we're trying to raise
money for the southern nevada bicycle
coalition
it's been six months and i'm asking
everyone in las vegas
donate one dollar for every month that
we've lived without our family members
help us raise money for this good cause
our goal is to raise twelve thousand
dollars before the end of this weekend
and we've already raised forty three
hundred dollars
so go to tmg or go to the southern
nevada bicycle coalition
and donate help us we have a lot of work
to do
we're looking for the community to be a
part of our team
and angela ahmet is going to come and
share her story now
hi i'm angela ahmet
wife of axe why am i
it's been six months since i lost my
husband my life partner
the father of my children
we are broken nothing will fix that
nothing will bring him back
and we know that it's not just us that
feels his pain this devastating tragedy
tragedy has robbed the community
axoy was a loving motivating father his
family were everything to him
and our children have lost his wisdom
and his guidance
he was also a writer who participated in
groups across all levels
and enjoyed all of them were members of
breakaway cycling
because it was important for him to give
back to the community
to get children on bikes he wanted
everyone to experience the joy of riding
the way that he did
he always had tips and suggestions for
new riders
all with shared encouragement and
whatever the ride someone undoubtedly
received some form of encouragement from
axoy whether it was a nice pool
as he as he took over on the rotation or
a good job or just keep spinning
and it's that same encouragement that he
offered up on every ride that is the
reason our children
are the amazing young adults they are
today because he was always there to
encour
to encourage and guide them
so why am i here the only solace when
facing tragedy
is to advocate for change so that more
families don't have to face the same
heartbreak that we're going through
so we must ask ourselves what could have
been done to have
prevented this tragedy
is very easy to simply state that
parsons should not have taken drugs
that's a given it's obvious that no one
should get behind the wheel
while impaired but i'm relatively sure
that there were people in barton's life
that knew he was taking drugs
yet they chose to ignore it to let him
continue to drive
friends don't let friends drive drunk we
all remember that right
but someone let him drive knowing he was
impaired
despite having a record of drug abuse he
was able to hold down a job driving a
truck
he was not merely driving himself home
at night
from a night out nor getting to work
while still under the influence the
morning after
he was driving a vehicle of 26 000
pounds that became a lethal weapon
how is that possible
nevada's a gaming state as a casino
employee
you're required to have a gaming license
a dui impacts your ability to attain
that license
and would result in a possible loss of
employment
this same philosophy should apply to
drivers
cruise line employees may be hired for
multiple roles across the ship
whether it be as a member of the
entertainment team or a chef
or an electrician yet for every employee
the number one priority is onboard
safety
and they are all trained to help
evacuate the ship
and as part of their safety requirements
crew are not permitted to be under the
influence at any time when they're
subject to random drug and alcohol tests
why then do we allow truck drivers to be
employed without similar restrictions
if a pilot walked on board a plane high
i'm pretty sure someone
would stop him from taking off and
potentially killing all on board
why would companies allow employees to
get behind the wheel of a truck
without some sort of check and balance
that they're fit and able to drive
driving in any vehicle comes with the
responsibility of following the rules of
the road
to prevent accidents companies that hire
drivers to haul thousands of pounds of
cargo
need to ensure that their drivers also
take the proper
precautions while on the road no more
recklessness
no more ghost bikes thank you
you know i'm sorry to say i've been
involved with way too many of these and
as angela said you know no more ghost
spikes and
a lot of people remember it and see it
but
you have a preconceived idea of what you
think you're going to want to say and
then you listen to these people and you
listen to the
the hurt and the positive things that
the group is doing and the
the horrific things and that people be
left with so
that kind of just goes out the window of
what you had preconceived and
you know donna i learned something from
donna that i'd never thought of when we
were doing the
the memorial she she made a comment and
i'm sure i won't get it right but i'll
get the idea across that
you know when we lose a loved one they
die twice
the first time when we physically lose
them
and then the last time we speak their
name
and with ghostbike and all these people
around here
we're not going to stop speaking their
names we're going to set these white
bikes around
people are going to ask which they do
what their names were and we're going to
we're going to speak their names
and those that came before them um
i'm not going to bring that up right no
no i guess i will i mean matthew hunt
cara
dr cabane there's there's quite a few
that we've lost before that we will
continue speaking their names and
setting their bikes and
and these bikes for anybody watching a
lot of people ask quite often you know
what is a ghost bike and it's nothing
more
myself and ghost spike i see steve over
here and pablo and the rest of us that
have
that took this on we're a supporting
role these people for these people you
just saw that are doing the hard work in
the legislature
trying to go about putting their lives
back together we're gonna set these
bikes and continue doing it to remind
people
what's happened before what we can do to
avoid it again
and hopefully to start that conversation
and keep the conversation going with
with your kids with your family members
with your coworkers
to think
none of us will dare call and it wasn't
an accident somebody made a really bad
choice
when they should have knocked up behind
the wheel just like every one of us
hopefully
the people that are watching this make
that decision
make the right decision to avoid
anything make sure something bad doesn't
happen
put that phone down if it rings while
you are driving and if you have a
drinker
or two there's no excuse grab an uber
call a friend
and let's avoid this and as angela said
let's not have any more ghost bikes
i'd like to thank all of you for coming
out
gonna wrap it up thank you thank you all
for being here